Star Trek vs. Star Wars.
Batman vs. Superman.
SCP-096 vs. SCP-682.
We just can't seem to resist pitting icons
against each other.
What can we say?
It's fun to see how two powerful forces would
go up against each other, and which one would
come out on top!
Fortunately, at the SCP Foundation, we can
justify pretty much anything by saying it's
for research purposes.
Trying to make infinite money using SCP-914?
That's just research!
Giving a can of soda to SCP-999 to watch it
bounce off of the walls?
Research.
Making infinite margaritas with SCP-294 while
you're still on the clock?
It's totally fine, Ethics Committee!
It's just research!
Putting two SCP Foundation Mobile Task Forces
together and making them fight isn't playing
God and risking lives for your own petty amusement.
It's, say it with me now: research!
More specifically, it's cross-testing.
Sure, that term generally only applies to
SCPs, but people who ask too many questions
don't survive long at the Foundation.
Instead, let's talk about the answers to a
question we posed to all of you.
What if cross-tests were done on Mobile Task
Forces?
Which specialized groups would you test with
one another?
What kind of chaos do you think would ensue?
We asked our community here at SCP Explained
for your ideas, and you all really let your
creativity shine!
So, without further ado, let's see what happens
when we pit spy against spy, brain against
brawn, or the cold, calculated expertise of
the Red Right Hand against the unpredictable
nonsense of Dr. Bright.
Sharky Reynolds said, "I can't imagine MTF
Lambda-5 (White Rabbits) losing to any other
Mobile Task Forces.
I mean, being the first ones called if SCP-953,
SCP-106, or SCP-239 break containment and,
worst of all, working with Dr. Clef has got
to make their tolerance for pain through the
roof.
However, if I were to cross-test them with
one, I'd have to go with MTF Epsilon-9 (Fire
Eaters).
Something about a team trained to handle reality
warpers VS.
a team whose dreams of becoming Firebenders
kind of coming true sounds epic to me.
(On a side note, in a previous video that
also I provided a comment for, "Which SCP
Mobile Task Force Would You Join?", that radio
neutralizing MTF Lambda-5 agent looked shockingly
similar to me.
Should I be worried about the possibility
that the foundation knows what I look like,
or that I may have just made Dr. Clef angry?)"
Resemblance to any existing commenters is
purely coincidental and not intentional on
the part of the SCP Foundation or any affiliated
YouTube channels.
Did I get that right, Dr. Clef?
Do you promise to leave my family alone?
Please, put down the chainsaw.
Back to your original point, seeing the White
Rabbits face off against the Fire Eaters would
certainly make for an explosive event!
Get it?
Because of the...fire...?
Moving on.
Chase Frost said, "Pandora's box vs Samsara,
they would be comparable.
Alpha-1 and Tau-5 would go to samsara every
time.
Samsara vs Able, and his hand-picked team
mates (whom could easily surpass Alpha -1
in skill) would be far more comparable.
Anomalous humanoid (and some of the most highly
skilled human combatants) vs anomalous cyborgs.
How could you turn that test down?"
Pandora's Box was technically disbanded following
the disastrous outcome of trying to harness
Able's bloodlust for the purposes of the Foundation,
but you can never rule out a reunion!
And an unkillable warrior with an insatiable
thirst for violence up against four cyborgs
made from clones of the flesh of a dead god,
with minds that can survive and be recovered
even if their bodies are destroyed?
That's the crossover of the century.
And, since no one involved can truly die,
it's a battle that would probably go on for
a century or more, too.
Jason Gutmann said, "Set Epsilon-11, "Nine-Tailed
Fox" against Nu-7, "Hammer Down" and see what
sort of armageddon would result from it, probably
involving heavy artillery, tactical combat
skills, and a couple nukes."
No thaumatology or reality warping here, just
good old-fashioned combat and a couple of
nukes.
I'd say that I like the way you think, but
it honestly just makes me kind of nervous!
No launch codes for you!
Unknown- how mysterious - said, "I am gonna
say the most obvious one, Alpha-1 (The Red
Right Hand) vs Omega-1 (The Law's Left Hand).
Two perfectly opposite groups.
One headed by the O5 Council and the other
by the Ethics Committee.
I seriously want to know how this will work
out.
Plus, there is a high chance that it has happened."
As equal opposites serving special interests
that frequently butt heads, it's entirely
possible these two groups have already gone
to war with each other in the past!
It's hard to say, since the Red Right Hand
would probably never let the story get out.
In fact, someone is looking at me through
the window right now and making a very threatening
gesture that makes me think I should stop
talking about MTF Alpha-1 immediately.
Moving on!
Katsen said, "Oh!
MTF Mu-13 “Ghostbusters” vs MTF Omega-0
“Ará Orún”.
Omega-0 are the “saints” of the Foundation,
the memories of dead foundation employees,
and depending on your interpretation, pretty
much ghosts working for the Foundation.
This would be a cross test!
Samsara vs Hammer Down would be one for the
ages as well.
I’m also curious how the City Slickers and
Village Idiots would fare against each other!"
You're far from the only commenter who proposed
pitting Samsara and Hammer Down against each
other.
In general, it seems that folks really want
to see Samsara fight with other Mobile Task
Forces, and it's easy to see why, since the
result would pretty much be an SCP-themed
Terminator movie on steroids!
But I'm more interested in the other pairings
you suggested.
Ghostbusters vs. what are essentially the
ghosts of the Foundation itself is too interesting
to ignore!
Meanwhile, Village Idiots vs. City Slickers
would be the perfect chance to see once and
for all if it takes more skill to contain
anomalies in the city or in the country.
Brandon Muzer said, "Lambda-5 ( white rabbits)
is my favorite mtf squad because I feel like
they would have to deal with the craziest
missions the SCP foundation has to offer and
we don’t get to see enough of them.
In would like to see them be cross tested
with omega-12 ( achilles heels) because they
are composed of reality benders, should be
fun and convoluted."
The White Rabbits specialize in navigating
unstable, surreal, and controlled reality,
and containing potentially dangerous persons
and artifacts capable of manipulating space
and time, while the Achilles Heels are a team
made up of reality-bending personnel from
an alternate universe.
Fun and convoluted is an understatement, as
a cross-test of the two might just result
in reality itself collapsing.
But hey, at least it would be entertaining
before everyone turned inside out or we all
fell into an alternate dimension filled with
giant shrimp or whatever.
Somebody - No, seriously, that’s their name
- said, "I would like to see Epsilon-9 "Fire
eaters" and Delta-14 "Winter Wonderland" They
have the opposites of jobs one is for fire
and another is for winter i like to see them
fighting"
Fire vs. Ice.
Simple, elegant, I like it.
Wouldn't know what to wear for that battle
though.
I'm thinking safety goggles, snow pants, and
flip-flops?
Commander Toolbelt said, "I would like to
see alpha 1 (the red right hand )meet the
bright 99 (oh no you don'ts) I just think
it would be funny seeing a super serious mtf
meet the goofy goobers that have to deal with
over 300 dr brights lol"
After all this time, the age-old question
would be put to rest: What's more dangerous,
physical violence, or the psychological toll
it takes to interact with 300 Dr. Bright's
all at once?
I say it depends on who gets a head start,
and if the Dr. Brights have access to any
props.
You should see what Dr. Bright can do with
a rubber chicken and a hand grenade.
It's not pretty.
Derek McDaniel said, "MTF-Zeta 9 (Mole Rats)
vs MTF-Lambda-12 (Pest Control).
I’m curious how would Lambda-12 that has
never lost a single operator (as far as I
know) fair against the Molerat team who face
so many unimaginable horrors that they probably
have the highest death counts out of all the
task force, and maybe the most experienced
veterans in the SCP Foundation."
The monotony of pest control vs. the unfathomable
horrors of the deep underground.
Honestly, instead of having them fight, maybe
we could just give both groups a free counseling
session instead.
Hannah Quintua said, "Hmm.
Eta-10 "See No Evil" which is for visual anomalies,
and Eta-11 "Savage Beasts" is for auditory
anomalies.
Let's see them work together."
A collaborative cross-test, rather than a
battle!
I like the way you think!
Putting those two groups together to handle
a mission as one would either be extremely
successful, or result in the auditory anomalies
harming Eta-10 while the visual anomalies
went after Eta-11, knocking both groups out
at once.
Only one way to find out!
Wooper Gamer said, "MTF Lambda-14 ("One Star
Reviewers") VS MTF Rho-9 ("Technical Support").
Neither of them likely have any fighting experience,
so it’s a fair fight."
Now that's what I'm talking about!
Some viewers want to see the most effective
combatants working for the Foundation go toe
to toe, but not you.
You want to throw two groups with basically
no combat experience into the ring together,
and see what happens next.
It would be one of the most low-stakes fights
in Foundation history, negative Yelp reviews
and "can I speak to the manager" vs. hacked
Instagram accounts and those annoying emails
that say "forward this to ten friends or you'll
be cursed!"
Or you could just give everyone a weapon,
take their computers and phones, and see what
happens next.
Linc said, "We gotta see Alpha-1 “Red Right
Hand” vs Nu-7 “Hammer Down.”
Alpha-1 is a highly sophisticated MTF Unit,
dedicating and risking their lives to save
the 05 Council, doing insanely risking tasks
that involve years worth of training not only
in fighting, but stealth too.
Meanwhile Nu-7 doesn’t give a damn about
stealth and just goes balls to the walls."
The resulting conflict would probably decimate
cities and fell national governments, but
it sure would be entertaining to watch!
FalconFig said, "I'd honestly like to cross
test my favorite MTF-Beta-777 (Hecates Spear)
and MTF-Gamma-6 (Deep Feeders) and see them
fight off deep sea eldritch entities.
Considering how Beta-777 specializes in thaumaturgical
combat, countermeasures, and rituals; they
would be very useful with Gamma-6 if something
like that scenario were to happen."
Another collaborative cross-test!
Hecate's Spear specializes in thaumaturgical
ritual analysis and countermeasures, while
the Deep Feeders specialize in the investigation
and tracking of deep-sea or oceanic anomalies.
In order for something to require both of
their skill sets, things would have to get
pretty darn Lovecraftian!
And I mean the real deal, not a super chill
Gamer Cthulu like SCP-2662.
Some real, mind-breaking cosmic horror rising
up from the deep.
Broad ford said, "I would find it really interesting
to put Delta-5 (front runners) against Sigma-66
(sixteen tons).
An MTF that specializes in infiltrating GOIs
going against an MTF that is made up of GOIs
sounds really appealing to watch."
Captured members from existing Groups of Interest
going up against a group dedicated to infiltrating
those same Groups of Interest would definitely
be appealing to watch!
But it would probably get a bit awkward too,
as more than a few covers wind up getting
blown.
Imagine working side by side with a guy in
your secret organization for years, only to
get captured by the SCP Foundation and find
out that same guy was working for them all
along!
Bob was a traitor all along.
Even when he signed your birthday card.
Even when you did a duet together at karaoke.
You wonder, was any of it real?
He promises that he really did see you as
a friend, not just a coworker and a means
to gather secret intel for the Foundation,
but some wounds never heal.
Dino Tales said, "I would have to say MTF-Θ-10
"Troops of Literature" (文字部队) and
MTF Tau-5 ("Samsara").
Who's better to take on narrative anomalies
and author entities than a team of cyborg
demigods they created."
Kind of a chicken or the egg situation there,
only instead of chickens and eggs it's incredibly
powerful supernatural cyborgs and creative
anomalies.
This fight would give a whole new meaning
to Death of the Author, that's for sure.
Derek McDaniel said, "MTF-Iota 10 (Damn Feds)
vs MTF-Pi-1 (City Slickers).
The two task forces (at least that I know
of) that work in urban environments and in
undercover.
How would these two face each other one way
or another?"
I can see it now!
The feds driving in nondescript black cars,
tailing the City Slickers down crowded streets.
I'm not sure why they'd be doing that, but
I really want to see a car chase, and this
seems like the best pairing to make it happen.
SolarKingYT said, "10 to 1 that any of them
would just sit down and have a coffee"
When you think about it, all of these groups
have way more in common than not.
They all work for the same faceless organization,
they all deal with life-threatening anomalies
in their own way.
Maybe instead of thinking about how they'd
fight, we should just let them kick back for
once, relax, and swap stories over a hot cup
of Joe.
Just...don't use SCP-294 to make it.
That could get bad fast.
Let them go to a Starbucks or something.
Now check out “SCP Elite Mobile Task Force
Explained” and “Which SCP Mobile Task
Force Would You Join?” for more!